So once again we need a new kind of number classification, one that goes beyond
just imaginary numbers and just real numbers. You can see I've drawn a new giant
rectangle around both of those families of numbers and labeled it with the name
complex numbers. So examining our new diagram, can you tell me which of the
following statements are true? All real numbers are complex. All complex numbers
are real. All imaginary numbers are complex. All complex numbers are imaginary.
All real numbers are imaginary, or all imaginary numbers are real. Please check
off as many of these as you think are true. Be careful in remembering how our
diagram works. In particular, how do you tell if one set of numbers is a subset
of another set?